Niccolò Machiavelli.
Probably one of the most
highly acclaimed philosophers
and political theorists
of all time.
Also, one of my
greatest influences
and a figure that has been referenced,
quoted, and misunderstood like few.
But before I initiate my attempt to
scrutinize Machiavelli and his philosophy,
I want to ask you a question.
When somebody mentions
the name Machiavelli,
or the terms Machiavellian
and Machiavellianism,
what is the first thing
that comes to your mind?
I assume that you think of words like
dark triad, duplicity, and manipulation.
Or in a broader context
the ability to gain power
through deception, insincerity,
and abuse of power.
Actually, those are all wrong.
They do play a role in the way Machiavelli
expressed his political theories,
but they all fail to paint an
accurate picture of the man.
If there is a word that could accurately
describe Machiavelli and his ideas,
it is this: Pragmatism.
He was probably the first
political theorist
that escaped the
delusion of idealism
and honestly proposed pragmatic solutions
and interpretations of government.
Apparently, his views were dramatically
influenced by the time he lived in
and his personal experiences,
oftentimes exceeding the threshold
of political correctness
and blurring the lines between
morally right and morally wrong.
Nonetheless, they constitute a
powerful compendium of knowledge
that is shaping the interpretation of
power and influence till this very day.
Niccolo di Bernardo
dei Machiavelli
was born in 1469 in
Florence, Italy.
His family was descended from
the old rulers of Tuscany
and they have
produced many members
that were part of the
government of the time.
Back then, Italy consisted
of many city-states
that were usually ruled
by different Houses.
Florence was among the largest
city-states in Europe
and was considered one of the
wealthiest and most successful.
Part of this success should be
attributed to the “House of Medici”
which was one of the strongest
families of the time.
The Medici controlled
the Medici bank
– then Europe’s largest bank –
and this allowed them to expand their
influence and strategic alliances.
In 1494, after a popular revolt,
the Medici were expulsed from power and
Florence was restored to a republic.
It was then that Machiavelli
received his first government role
as the person responsible
for the production
of official Florentine
government documents.
Machiavelli was part of a government
that wanted to liberate Florence
from the Medici reign, but
that was far from easy.
The Medici had a strong
alliance with the Pope
and their recapture of
Florence was a matter of time.
Machiavelli’s career was quite
turbulent and ended sadly in 1512
when he was deprived of office after
the Medici won a critical battle
that helped them emerge
to power once again.
In 1513, the Medici accused Machiavelli
of conspiracy against them
and had him imprisoned
and tortured.
After denying involvement,
he was released
and decided to retire to his estate
at Sant’Andrea in Percussina
in order to devote himself
to studying and writing.
That’s when he completed his seminal
works “The Prince” and “Discourses”
and that’s when he
gained his reputation
as a great political
theorist and philosopher.
When Machiavelli turned to the
question of whether it was better
for a prince to be loved or feared
he stated that while it would be
wonderful for a leader to be both,
he should eventually
side with fear.
Machiavelli suggests that human
nature is somewhat ungrateful,
fickle and dissembling.
The prince (or any
person in power)
is like the authority figure that
substitutes the parent figure
when a person enters adulthood.
People in power will always have a huge
responsibility towards their followers.
This responsibility creates
a form of dependency
that urges people to
keep craving more
and hold the prince accountable
for most of their needs.
Such an intense interplay
damages most of the ability
to cultivate self-reliance
and people, instead of appreciating
the prince’s offerings,
they become ungrateful and
keep asking for more.
Therefore, a prince needs
to resemble characteristics
that don’t allow others to
question his authority.
Such a characteristic is fear.
Fear, although it still
creates a dependency
between the ruler
and the people,
it successfully prevents
unwanted behaviors
stemming from lack
of appreciation.
The trick here is to ensure that
fear doesn’t turn into hatred.
Intense, cruel and unjustified
demonstrations of fear
can never keep people engaged.
Fear needs to be subtly induced in
a way that people can justify it.
Events of punishment should be
subject to convincing reasoning,
for people will side with the
most persuasive argument.
In Chapter 15 of “The Prince,”
Machiavelli states the following:
“Men have imagined republics
and principalities
that never really
existed at all.
Yet the way men live is so far removed
from the way they ought to live
that anyone who abandons
what is for what should be
pursues his downfall rather
than his preservation;
for a man who strives
after goodness
in all his acts is
sure to come to ruin,
since there are so many
men who are not good.”
In this passage, Machiavelli exudes
the totality of his pragmatic ideals.
He exposes the reality
of human nature
and explains that being constantly
nice will get you nowhere
because most people
are not that nice.
In short, he tries to explain that
a prince should destroy the delusion
that acting good will always favor him,
but at the same time create the
illusion that he is actually good,
for people respect goodness.
In general, some
personal characteristics
will earn people praise,
others condemnation.
Courage, compassion, faith,
craftiness, and generosity
number among the qualities
that receive praise.
Cowardice, cruelty,
stubbornness, and miserliness
are usually met
with condemnation.
Ideally, a prince would possess all the
qualities deemed “good” by others.
But this expectation is unrealistic.
A prince’s first job is
to safeguard the state,
and alas, harboring “bad” characteristics
is sometimes necessary for this end.
The relationship between the prince and
the people is quite a turbulent one.
People demand actions,
but at the same time,
they are not ready to react
maturely to difficult situations.
In order to understand the impact
this dynamic has in the relationship,
we need to work with an analogy.
Think of a difficult romantic
relationship you had.
After the honeymoon face,
reality hits you hard
and most times one of the parties
will let their mask of sanity slip.
False expectations, neurotic
reactions, unmet needs,
and increased familiarity
will lead to friction
and an inability to maintain
a stable connection.
Despite your most courageous
attempts to be honest,
your partner keeps reacting negatively
to news that don’t suit their liking.
Your ability to communicate
honest views decreases with time
and inevitably you become dishonest
in order to avoid conflict.
In a romantic relationship, usually
you have the luxury to leave,
but a prince doesn’t wish
to abandon his position.
He decides to embrace dishonesty
as the most effective weapon
to deal with lack of conflict.
People will almost always favor a
delusional hope to a harsh truth.
In Chapters 6-9 of “The Prince,”
Machiavelli explains what
a prince needs to do
after he acquires his position depending
on the way he ascended to power.
The overarching theme
of this idea is that
loyalty needs to be
constantly scrutinized
and bought and resistance
to be crushed.
When it comes to loyalty, the people
who decide to be on the prince’s side
will do so because they can benefit
from him and not because they like him.
They are bound to the prince
and their loyalty is a matter
of character and benefits.
The prince needs to ensure
that the rapacious and overly
ambitious shouldn’t be trusted
and that the weak-spirited
and grateful
should be sought after
and constantly praised.
That is a subtle but great
detail to identify.
Overly ambitious people
can’t stay loyal for long.
They are also thirsty for power
and eventually will try and
sabotage those above them.
In contrast, people
who are weak-spirited
will always savor their
relationship with a prince
because it allows them to feel safe
and that they belong to his tribe.
When it comes to resistance
Machiavelli recognizes resistance
as an omnipresent force.
That is because people are naturally
resistant to change and reform.
Especially people who benefited from
the old order will resist fiercely.
Princes who keep the
old order around
will inevitably need
to keep fighting them
and that suggests a waste of
time, resources, and trust.
Ergo, people who resist,
need to be crushed
on a whim and fast
so that the prince can focus
on reassuring the followers
of the strength of the new order
and the benefits that will follow.
In Chapter 25, Machiavelli
tries to conclude his ideas
with the main strategy to be followed
by countries and individuals
in order to increase their
chances of success.
Free will vs determinism has always
been a hot topic among thinkers.
Machiavelli’s stance on the
matter is again very pragmatic.
According to him, success is the point
where preparation meets opportunity.
A person cannot control the world,
but he can definitely control
most of his actions.
Through foresight,
people can shield themselves against
misfortune and self-sabotage.
Moreover, because time changes,
a prince needs to adapt and embrace
malleable characteristics.
On the whole, impetuosity
surpasses caution
and fortune favors energetic
youth over cautious age.
Machiavellian tactics and
strategies might come across
as quite caustic and
even dangerous for some.
For me, his works are invariably
imbued with a sense of awe
and they constitute a
combustible body of knowledge.
Actually, “The
Prince” is suggested
in most political science programs
around the world as a must-read.
This is not by accident.
Those principles have
been espoused and applied
by the most successful political
figures of our past and our present.
Knowing and understanding
those principles
can be a crucial step forwards in
redressing the balance within ourselves
and eventually within
our political system.
Hi everyone,
Today’s video was something I was
really looking forward to creating.
And that’s not only because
Machiavelli is one of the thinkers
that have influenced
my worldview,
but also because I wanted to shed
some light on some misconceptions
that tend to be associated
with him and his philosophy.
Additionally, in our current epoch
where politics are not considered
anymore this elusive concept
that seems so far-fetched
and abstract,
but more like a skill
with certain mechanics
that can be construed
and cultivated,
it is our duty to look
into its mechanics
in order to understand the extent
to which we can influence it
and as a result improve and
evolve our political system.
As always, if you enjoyed this
video, make sure to like it
share it with people that you
think will benefit from it
and if you haven't
done so already,
subscribe and hit the
notification button
so you can be informed when I
will release my next video.
Finally, I encourage you to express
yourself in the comment section below,
but please do so in a civil way,
and check out my
social media profiles
and all my ebooks in the
description of this video.
Thanks again for watching.
Take care.